bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans sa zone
qu'a dit ce matin nous allons parler de
prévention de l'obésité avec notre
invité manuel vestris manuel le bonjour
madame vous êtes cadre infirmière au
centre de soins médicaux et de
réadaptation
la valériane à trinité alors il faut
tout de suite précisé que ce centre de
la valériane se sait assez mr donc
centre de soins médicaux et de
réadaptation est un centre de référence
pour l'obésité et vous-même manuel
vestris c'est l'un de vos chevaux de
bataille depuis déjà plusieurs années
effectivement donc la valériane qui est
située à trinité c'est un centre comme
vous le disiez de soins médicaux donc
avec un volet privilégiés qui est celui
du traitement de l'obésité et du
surpoids et de l'obésité en martinique à
la fois pour les adultes mais aussi pour
les enfants seuls établissements qui
proposent une prise en charge familiale
pour les enfants on va détailler tout
cela mais c'est important de le
souligner manuel vestri justement avec
le retour d'expérience que vous avez on
va un peu planté le décor s'agissant de
la martinique de ce point de vue est
selon des chiffres que j'ai retrouvé de
la rs qui date de 2016
on nous disait on nous présentait la
martinique comme ayant près d'un enfant
sur quatre et plus d'un adulte sur deux
soit la moitié de la population qui est
en surpoids ou obèse et la rs indiqué en
2016 que la prévalence de l'obésité
continué de croître dans la population
martiniquaise surtout chez des enfants
tout à fait alors cette étude qui a été
faite presque est à 10 ans était l'étude
canaris qui montrent effectivement la
prévalence de l'obésité chez les adultes
et chez les enfants et aujourd'hui on
peut dire qu'un adulte sur trois est en
obésité et qu'un enfant sur dix est en
obésité en sachant que les chiffres du
scion poids ils sont aussi importants et
dans toute la population n'y a pas de
différence entre les hommes et les
femmes
donc toute la population était concernée
en tout cas sur les dix dernières années
est ce qu'on peut dire qu'il y à une
augmentation finalement que tout ça
c'est les chiffres effectivement les
chiffres montrent qu'effectivement il ya
une augmentation en gros deux points
pour les enfants et 2
trois points pour les adultes donc le
problème reste un problème de santé
publique
fléau même on peut dire et il faut s'en
occuper alors c'est pour ça que vous
êtes là aussi pour ce matin parce que a
commencé cette semaine
la période d'inscription pour la
campagne annuelle de prévention de
l'obésité infantile dont on va y venir
vous donc proposé une sorte de session
ben je sais pas comment appeler ça un
stage en tout cas un accompagnement pour
les enfants et les adolescents donc
expliquer nous justement ce qui a
commencé là cette semaine
alors peut-être juste avant re définir
la notion d'obésité qui met ce qui fit
ce qu'il faut entendre comme une
pathologie l'obésité c'est
l'accumulation de graisse corporelle de
manière anormale et de manière excessive
et cette accumulation là qui peut nuire
à la santé
donc on a on a les études médicales ont
montré qu effectivement on peut avoir
des complications comme le diabète comme
l'hypertension et ça ce sont des
chiffres ce sont ces temps une situation
qui demande qu'on travaille à la fois en
amont en prévention et aussi dans la
partie curative et c'est dans cette
partie là particulièrement que se situe
le programme ou qu'on propose à la fois
aux adultes et aux enfants qu'on appelle
un programme éducatif et donc qui est
proposé si vous voulez on peut commencer
par les enfants non oui oui oui mais
c'est ce que ce que je veux dire c'est
que là vous proposez donc aux familles
de pouvoir s'inscrire pour une formation
qui aura lieu dans quelques semaines
alors le programme éducatif pour
l'enfant se situe entre le moins de
juillet et le mois de d'avril
on en a on a privilégié les périodes de
congés scolaires tout simplement parce
que nous n'avons pas d'école intégré et
donc ça permet aussi aux parents on
regarde le programme est d'organiser
deux séances sur chaque conte jusque
chaque période de congés scolaires pour
pouvoir justement venir à la valeur
anne participer à la fois à des
consultations individuelles à des
consultations avec une équipe
pluridisciplinaire mais aussi participer
à des ateliers collectifs donc l'intérêt
lassé d'avoir cet accompagnement ulti
pluridisciplinaire donc quand on dit ça
on parle de la diététicienne
on va y venir on va y venir de la façon
dont ça se déroule ses mais j'ai envie
de faire de l'information pratique là ce
goulet et de dire parce que en fait
l'inscription se fait beaucoup en amont
par rapport voyez vous parlez d'un stage
enfin de qui aura lieu aux vacances
scolaires enfin pendant les grandes
vacances là on est on arrive donc au
début du mois d'avril
c'est dès maintenant qu'il faut se
préoccuper des inscriptions on va là on
organise comme une campagne annuelle
donc il ya une information qui est donné
à toutes à la population qui dit que à
cet endroit là valait rien ni à une
prise en charge qui existe c'est une
prise en charge familiale
enfants parents avec un début qui sera
sur des réunions d'information au moins
de juin et puis une fin de programme qui
est pratiquement sûr les vacances de
pâques
donc cette campagne-là permet déjà
d'avoir les formations et que chacun
puisse en fait chacun chaque famille
puisse aussi se rapprocher de son
médecin traitant récupérer un dossier
d'admission à la valériane et pouvoir
aussi avoir des informations comment ça
va se passer
qu est ce qu on fait ce qu'il faut que
je viens tous les jours nécessaires les
places sont forcément limitée manuel
vestris mais en fait elles sont
illimitées elles sont limitées par
rapport à effectivement à la capacité
d'accueil que nous avons par exemple sur
l'année dernière nous avions 70 enfants
inscrits donc ces enfants sont répartis
sur différents groupes des groupes d'âge
évidemment et qui nous permettent de
proposer un circuit à chaque groupe et
dans ce circuit à voir aussi une prise
en charge personnalisée par famille et
par enfant
alors le credo c'est surpoids et obésité
une affaire de famille justement c'est
ce que vous venez d'expliquer pour cet
accompagnement pour les enfants et
adolescents âgés entre 7 et 17 ans est
ce que est ce qu'il ya des familles qui
peuvent être prises en charge
simultanément en même temps est-ce que
ça vous est déjà arrivé qu'il y ait une
maman et un enfant par exemple qu'il
soit soigné parce que alors pas
simultanément parce que le travail est
édifiant et a besoin justement de cette
cette séparation de cette prise de
conscience déjà du parent que mon enfant
un problème de surpoids ou d'obésité
et puis après son problème un parent
peut tout à fait intégré le programme
éducatif pour les adultes ça c'est pas
ça ça ça se fait à ce sujet tout à fait
ça se fait alors comment comment se
passe comment se déroule cette prise en
charge
décrivez-nous un petit peu la prise en
charge elle disait donc on commence par
des réunions d'information on présente
le programme aux parents et ensuite
l'enfant intégrer le programme à partir
du mois de juillet sur une semaine
chaque groupe sur une semaine donc c'est
ce qu'on appelle une semaine
d'intégration où il ya ces premier bilan
sur les différentes disciplines
diététique éducateurs en activité
physique adaptée médecins et infirmières
donc et psychologues
c'est en tentant donc ses premiers
bilans là permettent on va garde de
profil et de mettre en place de faire un
diagnostic éducatif d'entendre les
besoins de la famille d'entendre aussi
les choses qui sont autour et qu'on ne
connaît pas forcément tout cas qui
pourraient avoir un impact sur la
l'obésité la prise de points et du coup
après le programme éducatif se déroulent
à raison de deux séances sur chaque
peuple dans ce que vous avez fait
allusion effectivement à l'intervention
d'un psychologue parce que souvent se
dit c'est assez logique bon le surpoids
l'obésité basse et l'alimentation il
suffit simplement de changer un petit
peu l'alimentation et les choses vont se
régler très vite à cinq ans si simple
que ça tant que ça ça y est comment je
vais dire ça il faut entendre déjà que
l'obésité a une origine multifactorielle
donc il n'y a pas que l'assiette qui est
un problème ya pas que la sédentarité
qui existe qui fait le problème
il ya aussi tout ce qu'on peut 2 le les
troubles de comportement alimentaire
peuvent être conduits par différentes
choses par des situations de stress par
des situations familiales qui sont
difficiles peut être au siège de la cour
n'est pas si bien que ça dans sa tête
la conséquence celles entre la direction
et un voile à surconsommer d'aller pas
toujours les aliments les plus sains là
et j'ai envie de dire la référence et le
contexte actuel le confinement nous a
bien montré qu'en étant confiné chez soi
comme n'ayant en baisse d'activité
souvent on se tourne très facilement
même plus facilement vers la nourriture
est souvent c'est pas la nourriture
équilibrée on se tourne vers des choses
qui font du bien globalement c'est
souvent du succès souvent des aliments
riche et du coup évidemment la
conséquence c'est là la prise de poids
alors sur quoi vous travaillez
précisément et notamment les enfants
parce que c'est un public quand même un
peu particulier à qui des fois il est
parfois difficile de demander des
efforts de ce genre en tout cas vous
voyez concernant mon goût les choses qui
qui qui cette qui font plaisir qui
satisfont le cerveau il s'agit et c'est
vrai puisque on a affaire à des enfants
de manière ludique ça va de 7 à 17 ans
donc on adapte les outils à la
population à l'âge des enfants que nous
avons et du coup il s'agit déjà de
porter une information c'est quoi que
manger et équilibrée comment tu manges
qu'est ce que tu sais des aliments
qu'est ce que tu sais du sport est ce
que est ce que tu as compris à quoi ça
sert quels impacts ça peut avoir de
faire du sport est ce que tu en fais
déjà comment tu te sens toutes ces
petites questions là au départ qu'on a
on va dire qu'on a construit qu'on
arbres environ avec lequel on a
construit nos ateliers et qui permettent
aux enfants de prendre conscience de
tout je suis par rapport à ça et du coup
qu'est ce que je peux faire tout ça tout
en jouant tout en utilisant des outils
ludiques
à côté de ça l'intérêt c'est d'avoir
aussi le parent parce qu'il ya une
interaction évidemment c'est pas
l'enfant qui fait les courses et pas
l'enfant qui prépare les repas donc
comprendre aussi ce qui se passe dans la
famille ce qui se passe aussi dans la
relation parent enfant parce qu'elle
peut être aussi une source de prise de
points on se réfugie dans l'alimentation
voilà toujours un peu mieux relationnel
tout à fait et du coup quand on a fait
ce premier travail là on propose
justement que ce soit en diététique que
ce soit avec la psychologue que ça soit
avec l'éducateur en activité physique
adaptée aux le médecin de travailler ça
sur le long terme sur des petits
ateliers qui permettent justement de
consolider à la fois les acquis mais
aussi de pouvoir les transférer à la
maison et ça marche alors peut-être pas
systématiquement mais ça fonctionne
assez bien avec le recul vous avez des
chances que le travail se fait le
support principal c'est l'implication du
coup parents enfants et même de la
famille des fois on a on a carrément
papas et mamans qui viennent
et des fois on a aussi petit frère petit
soit parce que ça devient une histoire
de famille on ne dit pas on ne punit pas
un enfant lui faisant faire du sport on
évite la famille à faire des activités
physiques ensemble et du coup c'est
c'est l'intérêt de ces le soutien que
l'enfant peut avoir avec sa famille et
les parents s'impliquent donc dans cette
prévention ça c'est une idée c'est de
d'éviter d'empêcher que cette enfance et
adolescents deviennent aussi un adulte
obèse ça commence par du surpoids qui
malin n'a pas l'air finalement si grave
que ça et puis au fur et à mesure voilà
un moment c'est trop tard souvent
souvent l'enfant vient enfin en tout cas
le parent inscrit l'enfant ou le parent
demande d'une admission à son médecin
traitant soit parce qu'il y a déjà un
problème une conséquence ça peut être
simplement j'ai mal au genou ça peut
être j'ai mal au dos a peut être que je
suis essoufflée pour faire du sport ça
peut être aussi qu'à l'école on se moque
un peu de moi il ya quelque chose qui
ressemble au harcèlement et puis c'est
tout simplement une sensation de mal
être quelque chose qui fait que l'enfant
ne peut pas ne peut pas se développer
correctement et de manière au niveau
psychomoteur et du coup il ya besoin de
comprendre de se laisser aller
nous allons conclure manuel vestri se
vous êtes cadre infirmière on le
rappelle au centre de soins médicaux et
de réadaptation
la valériane à trinité vous nous parlez
donc de 2,7
campagne annuelle de prévention du
surpoids et de l'obésité notamment chez
les enfants et les adolescents
dites moi la valériane c'est un centre
privé
alors qu'est ce que ça signifie vraiment
rapidement c'est toujours l'information
c'est un coup alors comment ça se passe
justement la valériane est un
établissement privé ont fait partie
d'une fondation qui s'appelle partager
vie donc c'est un établissement de santé
conventionnés avec la sécurité sociale
ça veut dire que toute personne ayant
une couverture sociale peut sans
problème être admise à la valériane une
couverture sociale ça peut être lu et
compris le samu absolument absolument ça
peut être effectivement la mutuelle
c'est mieux comme ça peut être aussi la
mutuelle en fait les différentes
mutuelles qui existent donc il n'ya pas
y'a pas de frais à la cloche mais pas
certaines catégories sociales soit ce
type de pas du tout comparé au contraire
tout est ouvert à toutes et à tous les
tous les types de population alors donc
on a dit la période de dépôt des
dossiers
voilà le dépôt des dossiers va jusqu'à
la fin du mois de mai 28 mai le vendredi
28 on peut mettre en place les premières
réunions d'information qui permettent
qui permettent aux parents et aux
enfants de savoir comment ça va se
dérouler à l'essai classique un numéro
de téléphone est peut-être une adresse
mail pour ce que tu as fait alors ses
synthés risation peut-être j'ai oublié
de dire que c'était aussi une prise en
charge ambulatoire c'est ça c'est une
hospitalisation de jour l'enfant arrive
avec son parent vers 7h30 il repart
après le déjeuner 13h et du coup deux de
séance on a diet de grosse matinée par
congés scolaires
voilà donc un numéro de téléphone pour
l'hôpital deux jours donc le zéro 596
587 823 un numéro 2 de fax par dont le
zéro 596 585 824 et une adresse mail hdj
val @ fondation partage et vie.org donc
vous vous appelez le standard et vous
pouvez sans problème à voir les
informations et le moment sinon il
suffit d'appeler le standard de la
valeur l'adriatique
tout est merci manuel vestris venu nous
parler de cela ce matin bonne journée
merci